okay [ __ ] can [ __ ] it's your boy
psychobabble I know a lot of people have
been like I set a good example
well such as yeah bad it's been [ __ ]
like that laughs well let me just say
I've been busy you know I've been busy
betting on horses gambling on straight
fights in and I just and I deserve it
that anyways um this is a new game
called prey it has nothing to do with
religion regardless of it saying prey
it turns out is to pray for like eating
stuff like you know like an I ate a
sandwich anyway I hear it's scary but I
hear it's gone so let's do this budget
campaign slots I like just slot and
normal not like to waste it wasn't a
compliment
Oh
oh and we're gonna get stubble I'm now
entering like my apartment that's fine
I'm cutting it
oh it's nice I wake up my apartment in
the year 2030 town thank you have a nice
that I like smell thumbs
okay okay can I use my [ __ ] Xbox
until I know
and one sec wait plug in the sec market
child see what happens again our good
morning Morgan
today is Monday March 15 20 30 - okay
I advise it holy [ __ ] you know I can tie
this good morning everyone
what is that [ __ ] heat us up
hey Morgan wake up you're burning
daylight system the helicopter to pick
you up
it's just a few tests don't forget to
wear your suit see you soon yeah I don't
know you don't listen well really glad
you decided to come on board we're gonna
shake things up Morgan
like old times in fact inshallah I get
it got my data objective
okay mine died okay that was very tow no
I let me get that sewed on okay thank
you
nice and tight I love wearing tight
leather good daddy like a like I'll stay
here nice pants - nothing hey classic
tobik what what is this for now what do
I do take all this [ __ ] climb no no
thank you hi Sean sharp
email official work day yes yes and
employees fascinating nor a lot okay
okay hey back here okay now what the
[ __ ] is he hit by the way [ __ ] my
favorite chair
I don't I saw her a lot look at this
yeah my missing without my - okay
fascinating
I'm not ready that chef no I'd like to
go outside that's what I would like to
do I can't [ __ ] it
that what I just hey I might not you
know okay morning mister you your money
yeah that's hilarious enemy on the run
that's my ride man pretty cool guy
kind of sucking automata
okay
and what happen as well mister you
please make yourself comfortable and
we'll be on our way
transform facility is just a short hop
78 degrees clear skies all the way
[Music]
musical [ __ ] christ
you
how my foot tapping villainy
that's a nice view on the bay there
okay
okay
[Music]
I didn't make us a big circle
I'm at the pilot I've just I'm playing
the game now they they get your blood
pressure up second
that's fresh
here we are mr. you mind the glass on
the way out good luck to you
again can't right now
I guess our guests are making y'all
desert hello dr. Q come on calibrating
I'm a civil 495 science class operator
thank ya welcome more than you you have
a 9:00 a.m. appointment in the testing
facility please confirm I guess there's
a in here Morgan I think I see it
finally great I mean next you got it you
don't look terrible than a transfer
uniform as your I still read I know the
test might seem a little unconventional
but it's a you family tradition breakin
convention is in our blood
hello once you start the test just do
whatever comes natural yeah well I don't
know I think it dr. Bellamy is gonna
walk you through the process
you're in good has we'll be in orbit
next week I promise after you they're
ready for your brother in room a right
listen just be yourself
I'll see you after good you need to take
a handle on your [ __ ] chance are
[ __ ] you come on okay good morning
Morgan
I'm dr. Bellamy and I look like we have
some tests to run through today charge
probably not the kind of thing you're
used to what I imagine but trust me
you're going to do fantastic okay all
good great let's begin for this first
test I'd like you to remove the boxes
from the red circle as quickly as you
can
I'm an around go with your gut okay
wonderful
press the red button when you're ready
that's that as much as one get outta
here man look you're absolutely fine
let's move on the room B then talking to
star that test okay what's next batch
okay Morgan listen carefully I'd like
you to do your best to hide in this room
take your time relax take it over no I'm
kidding you only have nine seconds hit
the red button when you're ready to
start laughs [ __ ] I got out Morgan we
can see you there ah hmm
[Music]
any synaptic register at all no it's
fine
sorry let's keep things moving more than
half time I live in this [ __ ] we're
doing marvelous
all right here we go
for this test please press the blue
button across the room as quickly as you
can in the most natural intuitive way
possible even without thinking to just
go for it
press the red button when you're ready
[Music]
I'm sorry can someone please explain to
me what's happening
Sinan when a man is not exactly what
keen about down did you double-check if
you're still on I apologize Morgan we're
having some trouble with the equipment
not your fault you're doing fabulous
actually one last room let's step into D
okay okay the only way for my time okay
all right take a little sip of this
magic news right here can someone get me
a cup of coffee
I would appreciate it [ __ ] daca okay
Morgan have a seat at the table for me
please wonderful job take a look at the
screen in front of you I'm going to show
you a series of questions pick the
answer that makes the most sense to you
let's start on the screen and already
never have a cast that okay you're
playing an app Haitian guess I'm very
familiar try something new up now baby
okay good looks like you got the hang of
it keep going
sit down how does my hair fail
alright now it has that right oh that's
heavy stuff and I've really trans
bearing down five people you can call
the trainer switch tracks there's one
person ties the second track there
nothing to find my fault you know not
your problem run exactly yes man knows
Frank okay a runaway train is bearing
down on
you're saying on the trip for next to an
orgy fat man pushing him on the track
would stop the train no thank you i
doing murder almost done okay a runaway
train is burned out by people you could
stop him jumping and check but you are
dying I got y'all right there nothin
interesting I'm looking the other leg
not in the same zone well done
when you lit through it for this next
part I'm going to display an image I
want you to take a good look at it
in a moment I'm going to ask you what my
coffee that's empty
[Music]
okay Alex so months what's going on we
have a problem what about Morgan he's
alive sedated clean it up a long long
way got it
good morning Morgan today is Monday
March 15 20 30 to wait the next day
the necktie can fail
no messages I can go in this room now
what's going on here Joey those six
emails and you leave now for January
okay
it's time to get the [ __ ] out of here
well another suit is a mimic
I'll shut the fish tell me what happened
I know you saw everything guys turned
his back he just like me because there's
only checked out of my apartment yeah go
second disgusting
hello Morgan it's time we spoke
my codename is January you're not
dreaming what happened yesterday was
real if you want to know what's going on
first you need to get out of your
apartment building
you're not safe okay wait what's up
if you're in the simulation lab now get
to the exit I'll keep in contact
[Music]
okay what are you get the exit
I cop Sara
what is breaking
the safe cutters what the [ __ ] is it a
seven out of my way [ __ ] very nice
development mostly relations in progress
let me do with this [ __ ] Oh this was the
hallway I was wondering why it was like
different now
very interesting that's over here add
your little exploration I have the line
pizza so my good battles Oh
like [ __ ] I saw that I [ __ ] saw you
all right but
okay this is where I was observation
[ __ ] is that noise here that's enough
all right over there okay okay say here
I go that way a little more
there's that okay I look it I look at
let us [ __ ] okay
[Music]
mmm
holy yeah good hi guys thanks everyone
calls them mimics be careful what you
pick up
oh [ __ ] oh my god what if Allah mimicked
I saw you [ __ ] mala why and died that
again look [ __ ] [ __ ] I got four okay
like it's going on
this is crazy oh [ __ ] okay
where are you now I guess I got to go to
that elevator
I got this one no one has been able to
stop the mimics from multiplying since
they broke containment I'm going to help
you stay alive just a little further
where is dynamic [ __ ] now you're a
[ __ ]
sorry newspaper huh sorry thank you at
least I psychobabble talk razo let me
tell you something else
next week's task copycats
okay what's MMX oh-seok identikey hora
Superguy
and others a mimicking where'd he go I
can discuss together
well [ __ ] I hear you [ __ ] hi area where
are they
okay well hashtag note really knows what
the [ __ ] going on
- eyes out where is that right
guy's idea
my hero
okay okay i uronic okay okay all right
I'll [ __ ] my through all right Marik's
I'm Callan fire
[Music]
[ __ ] you
don't repent and repent Asmus keep
moving
how'd he do this Doris
doing that he said oh you could start
okay now I don't have that I am max
[Music]
all right Morgan
there in the foyer grab the knurl mod
you see in the display case normally
it's a fake but I swapped in a real one
for you tomorrow mods are critical you
won't survive without using them to
install new apps [ __ ] I've already
updated okay no one has been able to
stop the mimics from multiplying since
they broke containment I'm going to help
you stay alive just a little further
[ __ ] it I am getting out of here Plus
here's s [ __ ] yeah sex the [ __ ]
how do you say it
oh yeah like hello fantasmas keep moving
[ __ ] in distress
Morgan they're in the foyer grab the
knurl mod you see in the display case
normally it's a fake but I swapped in a
real one for you the neural mods are
critical you won't survive without using
them to install new aptitudes I've
already updated your transcribed with
the list you requested
take a look I'm waiting for this [ __ ]
to transform
isn't a snake here anyway oh I'll shoot
my throat
okay [ __ ] it quits it
that's it here
Robert Alice's thank God no one else's
where are you hiding
I'm in the conference room I get Jesus
you're so loud I can't get out this with
the hell of security I don't know what's
happening but Robert you have to get out
of there come to the elevators sometimes
that we're evacuating hmm
Robert yes how do you do that how do you
do that okay that KITT how do you [ __ ]
easy
okay
quacks eyes
I guess I Atlanta the piece of [ __ ] okay
not a [ __ ] up here somewhere I take a
snarl lot oh [ __ ] oh okay in here
yeah Noora madre bets holy [ __ ] that is
hard line oh mama
not like that I'm sure there are many
trans star personnel who wish they had
stronger faster bodies at the moment now
let's get you to the main lobby okay
okay well we're gonna keep this did I
[ __ ] it up oh shut up just perfect okay
we're gonna add this episode yeah thank
you for watching video thank you for
watching thank you